you like the Tangerine I decided and I
don't know how I feel about this I'll
let you know when we're halfway through
the show to not bring a perer on air
this episode and bring a lroy this is a
tangerine lroy I prefer orange lroy but
this will have to do dude
QVC we've got a beautiful
lroy tangerine
lroy and you know it's absolutely
unbelievable look at this
beautiful color
yellow
orange says right there
Tangerine naturally
essenced what does that even mean you
know that's nothing it basically means
it tastes
like maybe you thought about
Tangerine zero calor if you're talking
about calories there's zero
if you're talking about total fat
there's zero if you're talking about
total
sodium zero why you do it so loud if
you're talking about
carbohydrates zero if you're talking
about
protein
zero ingredients are carbonated water
and it is naturally asens now what does
it mean there H here's the thing about
now here's the about lroy there cannot
be something that tastes like something
if it's not in there so it is absolutely
cancer
causing there cannot be something in
here that tastes like
Tangerine that they are saying it is not
in here it can't be okay it is something
in here but they are saying it's nothing
nothing it's cancer they're
saying the only thing in
here is
water legitimately that's the only thing
that they are saying that's in here and
it tastes like
Tangerine this is why is nobody talking
about how impossible this
is M every single person who was
watching turn it off already it
simply can't Happ happen okay right we
can all agree yeah we selling it for
this this time only it's okay you just
drank cancer it's okay dude why do they
do that do what there's something in
there no one does what you did there's
something in there yeah and they're
saying there's nothing in there it
tastes like something so there's
something in there so what is it
ingredients carbonated water that's all
it says carbonated water comma naturally
essenced what is that we don't know but
obviously they're getting away with it
by just it's like there's there's an
asteris asterisk next to Essence and it
all it is the asterisk all it means is
non GMO so Essence all it means
according to this can is that it's non
GMO but what is it if it that's what I'm
the definition of a thing the definition
of a thing can't be non that's exactly
what I'm saying they're saying it's not
in there but it's in there no they're
not saying it's not in there're saying
now for only $2 this naturally essenced
whatever is non GMO but what is
naturally Essence exactly it's not in
there but it's in there $2 wow what the
what is it is cancer it will kill you
this beautiful
lroy sparkling water and there's too
many words on the front here too so
that's great think think lroy tastes
better than perier is out of control and
here's what I can't believe there was
one literally before we started this
there was one perer left in the
refrigerator and like dozens of lroy you
and I have had this discussion many
times you always say lroy is better you
chose knowing I exist to have the very
last perier in the refrigerator now
why'd you do that to gift you the
absolute beauty of Tanger now there's
too many letters words on here sparkling
water Tangerine naturally essenced
lacroy that's too many we can all agree
on that you didn't answer my question I
I I I don't like that trash [__] what is
that what what Tangerine lroy there's
lime there's PL is there lime in there
yeah you still chose to take the very
last Perry knowing that I thrive and
survive on perier I like perier better
now you do okay well now at least that's
a good reason changed I like per better
good it's better sorry stick you with
the Tangerine here's the thing though no
I like it's fine I I obviously like like
that better but okay I'm going rubbing
it in perier is twice as expensive as
the Croy right I I rarely am like
something's better just cuz it's
expensive but when something's TW $5 or
$10 the chances of the thing that's $10
being better are exponentially high and
yet there are people in this world who
actually say to my face straight to it
lroy tastes better than Perry You're
crazy you're absolutely
crazy if you want your water to taste
like really shitty water down candy here
I go here you go I got the thing that's
right for you if you want your water to
taste like water there you go it's over
there my brother took the last one
didn't let me have it you're doing a a
QVC for perer then yeah but I'm doing it
from the heart I know